so we'll take five suggestions i'll
divide you up into segments so we get a
kind of fair shout out uh let's come to
you guys here what do you want to hear a
rap about
toenails just wow two things that could
not be further apart
uh toenails and quantum mechanics uh
okay
i feel like you know when you clip a
toenail and it disappears it could be in
any place at the same time so that's uh
you know almost uh almost the uh the
heisenberg uncertainty principle there
just to flex that education okay so
toenails maybe quantum mechanics
throwing on that toenails first uh back
of the room what do you want to hear a
rap about
you you've got your brain fixated on
feet now so no no
no shoes no shoes chad what's the other
one
in the chinese currency and and crypto
is in cryptocurrency
cool two people in this room understand
that one is him one is me
so crypto and the yuan so chinese
cryptocurrency
toenails maybe quantum mechanics uh this
little segment here what you want to
hear a wrap about
the tupler effect you really just you
know we're just like let's just say
things we saw tonight
you said tequila um
what hindenburg wow okay
the doppler effect the hindenburg
harry potter that feels very just
pointed like a heckler just
okay so say what you said tequila you
said harry potter let's combine those
that's quite fun
harry potter and tequila hindenburg
cryptocurrency and yuan
toenails and the doppler effects okay
that's five that'll do
um this then lovely people no you can't
say sausage that's a food
forbidden also just a creepy thing over
there just like sausage
yeah i i like you a lot but no
so okay that's how we're gonna do we're
gonna take those suggestions
uh we're gonna do a freestyle rap that's
a wrap made up on the spot based
entirely on those suggestions not
prepared
not written down never to be performed
or seen again and don't worry it won't
be anywhere near as bad as you're
expecting it to be
wow you're so unconvinced by that okay
should we drop that beat my friend
this is going to be about cryptocurrency
and the one
toenails the doppler effect the
hindenburg
and harry potter and tequila somehow
we'll knit those together
i'm excited for this even if none of you
seem to be and can you pump that volume
as well
pump it a bit more that's what i like
the sound
my toes got that hair growing too long i
see the toenails too strong
i let my keratin grow out i sing a song
when i do it
usually a sound of pain i got the fungus
on there i'll never do it again
through a swimming pool with no socks on
when i clip my tail no yeah where it
gone tail no i meant toenail flip the
world around
let me see the ambulance coming by the
sound that's the doppler effect
where's it going next the pitch starts
high and then it's directly down the
street the pitch goes lower as it moves
don mcmillan on stage he proved how it
worked
it's the frequency i can't move on there
with secrecy
like the chinese government out in
beijing cryptocurrency
it's a real thing bitcoin an ethereum
if you've got a lot of that you're a
wealthy man but if you go
to the republic of china get a little
coin out yeah it's a shiner see all the
sunlight reflect
off the currency they're not doing that
well though currently
a trade war coming on between here and
china yeah the white house in fear
saying oh gab
yeah we got those tariffs god keep the
money in that balance
if you don't study it fiscally there's
no laughs in here it's a risk for me but
that's okay
yeah i'm gonna move on quantum mechanics
yeah not the u1
i'm gonna say particles in space could
be any time like tequila in my face when
i'm knocking down my neck
i take a lot of shots i'm in the bar how
many yeah i forgot
i look all of the glasses i try and
count them up the next in
yeah hold them up your wands are mean
i'm gonna say this i'm a charmer let me
take it off you
expelliarmus what a magic trick you can
do harry potter
can you refill this empty bowl a tequila
get me jose cuervo sounds like a spell
that they do
and i do know you can ask him come from
far
harry potter how did you get that star
well actually i was drunk on the worm
juice
i was walking around here's the mad
proof i stumbled and broke my glasses
when i get drunk on tequila the girl's
asses look
so fine i've observed i crash and i burn
like the hindenburg
coming in the early 20th century you
tried to land there
it was meant to be but didn't employ all
the humanity
all the german people die and they were
set free it was burning
never do again careful don't fill with
the hydrogen because it's flammable
fools when lightning strikes it's not
gonna end well
no not right all these people burning
one little fact there's still one
survivor where does he live
actually in northern colorado this is
true i studied this year i really do go
i think he lives in a place called
parachute
or rifle i've got to look it up tell you
the truth chris we didn't know these
people live for so long
it's true yeah i've got a really long
schlong why would i say that yeah i am
the boss yeah i don't call it a [ __ ]
long i call it a sausage
you